hey friends so I want you to check out
what I think is one of my favorite
beginner po tricks this right here is
the windmill it is an amazing POI trick
not just because it's really the first
thing that we learn that forces us to
change our levels with POI but also it
integrates really well into things like
waist wraps giving us access to things
like the fourbe fountain as well as
being able to open up into bigger volume
tricks like this variation that we
sometimes call po truvian man but how do
you get your windmills down well I know
three distinct methods for doing it and
I'm going to guide you through each and
every one in the course of this
video Drex here from Drex Factor po
sharing with you the love of pois
spinning and flow Arts to benefit your
body and brain and today we're going to
dive into po windmills and hopefully
we're going to find a way way that I can
get them across to you in a way that'll
make sense but before we dive in I just
want to give a quick shout out to the
Friends of the channel big thanks to
dark monk fire Mecca flow fests flow
toys pyro Tera light toys and Ultra poy
for helping to make the videos on this
channel possible you can learn more
about all these awesome companies and
the work they're doing to support flow
artists like yourself by checking out
the links down in the description of
this video and special thanks to the
non-b buus friend of the channel Becca
Beck Glen thank you so much for
supporting my channel my work and my
mission all right so the POI windmill
the theory on these is pretty easy to
understand as things go basically I am
just performing a two beat that is
something like a Tic Tac going back and
forth across my body but I'm doing it
here in wall plane that is uh spinning
my POI as though they are brushing up
against an invisible wall in front of me
and doing it up here around my shoulders
I think that these are called windmills
because they look more or less like a
windmill's blades turning around up high
and of course this is a py trick that we
do up around our shoulders so we are
also doing it up high it also does
present a little bit of a challenge
though because this is one of those
first places where we have to learn a PO
trick where the reach is just a little
bit uncomfortable so it does beg the
question of how exactly do we pull this
off so in the course of my POI career I
have encountered three different methods
for teaching this trick the first is the
first one that I ever encountered that
I'll refer to as the cork screw method
the second is what I'll refer to as the
shoulder reel method and the third is
what I'll refer to as the Russian method
because I learned it from some Russian
po Spinners I think all of them are good
in their own ways and they all also have
drawbacks so I'm going to walk you
through each one and you can decide for
yourself which of these approaches is
the best one for you to get down your
POI windmills all right so first up
let's talk a little bit about the cork
screw method cork screws were something
that were pretty intuitive for me to
pick up when I first got into po
basically they involv just taking the PO
around back behind your head and then
back in front of you I've done tutorials
on cork screws as well I can go ahead
and list them down in the description as
well as up in the cards but the long and
short is that we're going to go ahead
and just spin our POI around in Split
Time same direction in a horizontal
plane here I'm letting my right hand
lead both of the POI as they go back and
forth up and down like so now if you've
got down your cork screws there's a
really weird trick that you can use to
turn these into windmills and that is
that you bend over into them so that all
of a sudden the cork screws are going
around your head rather than say in
front of you or above and below your
head now from here you can begin the
work of kind of straightening up of
trying to keep the POI in the same
orientation relative to your head that
they are when you're performing the cork
screws but of course you try and return
to a more
vertical kind of uh positioning here a
more vertical kind of stature and by the
time you get fully vertical in theory
you should be performing a windmill now
caveats going with this are that I
actually do find it quite difficult to
make the transition from the horizontal
plane up into the vertical plane this
took me several weeks to learn how to do
uh and when I finally did it I
discovered that I was performing a
windmill in the opposite direction that
I meant to I was performing a windmill
going around counterclockwise when my
dominant Direction has beenin is
clockwise and eventually I had to go
through and learn this in both
directions but it does work it just
takes a little bit of time and it does
kind of make use of a trick that may be
a little bit more intuitive for you in
order to get to that final position all
right so let's talk about method number
two this consists of learning the
windmill as a series of shoulder reels
the first windmill tutorial I ever
uploaded to my channel in fact used this
method and it works something like this
basically you want to turn your entire
upper body over towards your stage right
and get the Poise spinning forwards in
Split time Same Direction with your
hands up near your ears you're going to
pay careful attention to that poy in
your left hand and as it passes by your
elbow you're going to follow it around
and you're going to turn over to your
stage left now the poy appear to
spinning reverse in Split time Same
Direction with your hands up near your
ears watch very carefully for when your
right hand is going up towards the
ceiling and when that happens you follow
it around back over to Stage right so
you follow the left po over to stage
left and you follow the right POI back
over to Stage right makes sense you're
going back and forth between having the
POI spinning forward split times same
direction and reverse split Time same
direction keeping your hands above your
shoulders once that gets to feel kind of
normal you're going to try and do a
specific number of reps in each spot
here so I'm going to start off thinking
I'm going to do 10 9 8 7 6 5 4 3 2 one
reps before I turn and 10 9 8 7 6 5 4 3
2 1 before I turn again make sure you
can do 10 reps of that not just spinning
the PO for 10 times but going back and
forth 10 times when that gets to feel
comfortable cut the number in half
thinking 5 4 3 2 1 and turn and 5 4 3 2
1 and turn once again be able to do this
10 times once that gets to feel
comfortable I want you to instead go to
reps of three thinking 3 2 1 and turn
and three 2 one and turn like so from
here you're going to go down to just
thinking one
two reps one two reps one two reps one
two reps and then just think that it's
going to be a single rep following left
following right folling left following
right following left following right and
by now you should be picking out that we
have hit a windmill the windmill is just
us taking the shoulder reel straight
back and forth like so now learning with
this method also takes a while and it
also gets you really comfortable with
moving your hands and pois up near your
shoulders you're going to wind up with a
lot more control learning it by this
method and of course also you're going
to wind up in a place where more body
movement is involved in keeping the
windmill going rather than just being
strictly through your hands I think all
those things are good things overall the
downside once again of course is that it
does take a little while to learn this
way and you need to get down some of
those fundamental skills of just being
able to keep the Poise spinning up near
your shoulders for a long time you will
feel this one in your shoulders I
guarantee it um but I think that the
control you get out of it kind of
offsets that now all that said if you
want a foolproof method that doesn't
take as long uh we do have one more
method for you here but before I drop
that method on you if you come this far
I'm guessing it means that you are into
POI and flart's videos which if so I
have great news cuz I upload lots of
those and if you'd like to see more of
my videos and especially the new ones as
they drop what I'd love for you to do is
subscribe to the channel and ring a bell
so you know exactly when that happens
not only do you get to see new videos
right away but also it helps my channel
grow so everybody wins thanks in advance
all right so here's our last method
which I will also call the Russian
method here's how it works uh
essentially you're going to start over
on your stage left with your Poise
spinning reverse and I want you to first
drop your left hand Po and then your
right hand poy behind their respective
shoulders again
we bring the left hand back and then the
right hand back and you bring the PO to
a stop back behind your shoulders you're
going to turn over to your stage right
and you're going to pull out your left
hand and then your right hand one after
each other we think left and right like
so you should now have the Poise
spinning forwards on your sides in Split
Time same direction we'll turn back to
stage left and do it again we're going
to drop the left hand and then the right
hand we turn over to Stage right and we
bring out the left hand first and then
the right hand cool cool all right now
let's start to work our way up to our
windmills here once again over here at
stage left I want you to drop the left
hand and then the right hand behind your
shoulders and as you come over to Stage
right I want you to do something
different this time rather than bringing
your POI out and keeping them spinning
for a while and then turning to your
stage left I instead as you pull those
po out want you to turn from stage left
or rather stage right to stage left all
in one motion like so we turn over to
Stage right and you want to imagine that
you're sweeping your left hand around in
a big circle in fact you can just
practice doing this with your left hand
to start with take just your left hand
swing it out and around in front of you
and then drop it back on your left side
turn to your right swing it around in a
big circle and bring it back behind your
left shoulder swing it out and around a
big circle bring it back behind your
left shoulder do the same thing with
your right bring it out and around in a
big circle drop it behind your right
shoulder when you're facing back over to
stage left from stage right here bring
it out and around in a big circle as you
turn and bring it back behind your
shoulder big circle bring it back big
circle bring it back big circle bring it
back big circle bring it back now we're
going to do it with both hands so as
we're faced over to Stage right here
you're going to first bring out the left
hand and then the right hand sweeping
left right and then bring them both
behind your shoulders again as you turn
back back over to stage left turn back
to Stage right Swing Out Left Right
bring them both back around again turn
to Stage right left right as you turn to
stage left and bring them both back
around sweep them around Left Right
swing them around left right like so as
you do this I want you to work towards
taking less of a pause when you bring
the poy back behind your shoulders try
to keep them in motion the entire way
around here so rather than stopping
turning and bringing them out you only
let them dip for a moment behind your
shoulders as you're making this turn
here it changes what feels like almost
doing stalls with the POI behind your
shoulders into doing something that
feels more like say a flower petal
perhaps as you're doing this and taking
them around you'll notice we've gotten
to what looks very much like a windmill
from here it's a Choose Your Own
Adventure you can either practice making
this motion a little bit smoother and
not having to turn your upper body from
side to side or you can try keeping your
hands up next to your shoulders and ears
the entire time rather than taking those
big swings around you just keep your
hands up close next to your head or you
can work on doing both keeping your
shoulders at minimum movement and
keeping your hands high and tight up
near your ears to give that classical
wind
presentation yeah okay so you've learned
your basic windmills now what next how
do you transition in and out of them
what kind of variations are there of
them out there what other exercises
should you be doing in order to really
get these down I'm so glad you asked
because that is the theme of the flow
Circle for December the flow circle is a
weekly exclusive lesson that's available
only to my patreon supporters and this
month the theme is windmills we'll talk
about everything from basic presentation
to how you do things like opening up
volume and into weird variations that
you may or may not have seen before plus
which I'll show you how to get down your
windmills going both ways and to gain
full fluency of movement with them to
sign up for this go check out the flow
Circle at
patreon.com direct Factor po the first
lesson is available now how did you
first learn windmills did you learn one
of the methods that I outlined in this
video if not I would love to hear what
other techniques there are out there go
ahead and leave me a comment and let me
know how you learn them
[Music]
this video and all the videos on this
channel would not be possible without my
amazing supporters on patreon in
particular I'd love to give a shout out
to my flow patrons who are listed on
screen right now thank you you all rock
and if you enjoy the content that I
produce and you'd like to see me make
more of it the best way to do that is to
sign up over at my patreon at
patreon.com drexfactor poy where you can
get access to a whole host of awesome
rewards but better than that you'll be
supporting me in my mission to bring po
spinning and flow Arts to the whole wide
world so go check that out please and
thank you and if you'd like to go
further down the windmill Rabbit Hole
perhaps you'd enjoy this video right
here I've made a lot of them over the
years and windmills have been a
particular interest for me so go check
that out I hope that you'll enjoy it in
the meantime thanks so much for watching
make sure to get out and flow yourself
today and I'll see you with a new video
real soon take care now peace